10888 cas confirmés du coc vide en
russie ce 5 octobre le pays s'approche
du pic des malades enregistrés en mai à
moscou l'épicentre de l'épidémie on
dénombre 3537 nouveaux malades ce lundi
le kremlin fait part de sa préoccupation
face à la hausse des chiffres bien sûr
l'augmentation du nombre de personnes
infectées est une raison très sérieuse
pour se mobiliser et être beaucoup plus
prudent dans notre vie quotidienne
cela concerne chacun d'entre nous quant
à un confinement je n'en ai pas entendu
parler pour l'instant
le maire de la capitale sergueï
sobianine a rapporté que la situation à
moscou et est en train de se stabiliser
mais l'a tout de même indiqué que le
nombre de moscovites hospitalisés chaque
jour s'approche de mille personnes dont
beaucoup de malades graves deux hôpitaux
de réserve dédiée spécialement
traitement de malades de coronavirus ont
été ouverts aujourd'hui le ministère de
l'éducation a annoncé le retour aux
études à distance dans trois régions
russes dont moscou
le taux face à l'épidémie la mairie de
moscou a annoncé des vacances de 15
jours pour les écoliers à partir du 5
octobre
cette mesure s'ajoute au rétablissement
du télétravail dans les entreprises
ainsi qu'amr au confinement pour les
moscovites de plus de 65 ans les gens
souffrant de maladies chroniques graves
les autorités appellent les moscovites à
respecter les gestes barrières afin
d'éviter leur au confinement général qui
reste toujours une des options possibles